see uh
of course aram harrow who you know needs
no introduction here he's
been on panels before but he's uh he's
of course the from mit and
author of the
uh hill um
algorithm for linear systems but also
you know various things on quantum
machine learning
and maria schultz uh who is uh
who is um from xanadu the toronto-based
startup as well as um
i believe she's she got a phd from
kwazulu natal university in
in durban where she is also a researcher
she's written a book on supervised
learning with quantum computers
and
and we have
jared mclean from google um
got his phd from harvard
and he's actually the author of the
first paper on on on baron platters so
welcome everybody and so so we'll start
by uh
possibly giving everybody on the panel a
few minutes to
to
comment on on nathan's talk as well as
to comment on this this general area of
baron plateaus quantum machine learning
you know just
please take it away so
um i could start
yes please
okay cool
so nathan well and everyone on the panel
also knows me that i love to kind of
like challenge sometimes a little bit
the the basic wisdom and um so nathan
thanks for the cool talk and i find it
really cool that you kind of turn around
the idea of brand platforms look into
generative models
um but i want to change you on the first
slide and basically this change goes to
the entire community and also including
my own work so it's not a nasty kind of
part of criticism but also like a
self-reflection
and when you look at your first slide
and also like
the following slides we always talk when
we talk about quantum models as i want
to call them so these are these like
quantum circuits we interpret and we
train like machine learning models
we always talk about like general
unitary so we always saw like a u and n
or we saw a row or something like that
and so i started thinking more and more
in the last year that maybe one of the
biggest mistakes we're doing in quantum
machine learning at the moment and why
we're finding these bearing plateaus
that we analyze and then go deeper and
deeper into theory
come from the fact that we do not
specify much clearer what we actually
mean as a model
and so to give you a little bit of an
intuition there if you go to classical
machine learning what we for example
replace could be something like a neural
network or maybe a
an sdm or something like that and in
your network for example is a very
specific function class
now you could say a neural network is
also very general function class and
there are a couple of subtleties
comparing you know function classes and
and you know like universal quantum
algorithms and so on so forth however
if you like look a little bit into the
theory of deep learning then you will
have heard that training
neural networks and this whole deep
learning regime
means that we somehow limit this
function class in real life so i would
still say that there's a big limitation
so my my question to challenge this a
little bit and patrick holds already
like that that's you know maybe it's a
bit of a simplification of the whole
topic but isn't the reason that we find
baron plato's simply because we haven't
got the um
how can i say those like the we haven't
done our homework and actually saying
what a quantum model is
and yeah i can add a couple of thoughts
about that if anyone's interested
because in kernel methods we have a very
similar debate where people say so if
you know that there are these quantum
models that are very similar to kernel
methods people say but overlaps of
quantum states are also zero on average
yes but if we get the right model they
are not right so that's that's the thing
i want to put forward let's look for
this video a bit
yeah great uh actually um
um
is how long would it would it take you
to say well what should this model be
so i have absolutely no clue but um
i think um the questions we have to ask
they are actually kicking us a little
bit out of our comfort zone so for
example i think what happened is
we used these variation circuits and i
mean they were like invented and they
were taken i mean uh jared will tell us
nice stories about this i think but they
were taken from okay what's in the
quantum hardware and what the quantum
hardware had was poly rotations right
because this is what quantum theory was
based on so hardware tends to like
realize those the variation circuits use
power rotations and in quantum machine
learning we always build our circuits
out of the same party rotations this is
what's parametrized
and
if you think about it no one has ever
analyzed or even asked the question if
this is the right building block for
quantum machine learning model we don't
even know how to say something about can
we study a generalization very well with
them can they actually you know be
optimized very well so maybe and i don't
know the answer but maybe we have the
wrong building block altogether at least
at least one person in the world should
ask this question so that's the thought
about it but unfortunately
yeah maybe
i can give a response because i'll
probably end up riffing and agreeing a
lot with what maria just said which is
kind of uh twilight to kind of go with
your format i like nathan's talk a lot
thank you nathan because
i think it takes a unique approach to
trying to figure out how to modify the
objective function to repair some of
these problems and when we were
looking at where your narrative and your
introduction at the beginning actually
follows very closely how up at the
result which is we have been working a
lot with random circuits for other
reasons uh
and we noticed that all expectations
were concentrating was very hard to use
them in any way and i was hopeful maybe
that gradients provided some
nearness or escape from this and in fact
we ended up finding the opposite
but when we proved the result it it
stayed very much a concentration of
measure result in the sense that um we
got initial reactions where people are
like oh well this just means use
gradient free methods but that kind of
like misses the point that follows from
the concentration of measure what the
real problem is is you're in analog to
these results that came much before us
that said most quantum states are far
too entangled to be useful um and
basically i think this connects kind of
what maria was saying which is i think
the reason a little bit we're in this
situation it's not a phenomenon that's
unique to training variational circuits
but in fact you'd have this problem in
the embeddings if you didn't choose
smartly in say quantum kernel methods as
well is that you know how did we get to
the way we choose embeddings or training
circuits um initial bqe as maria said
was very practical was what could you do
on a device today
and why do we like random circuits we
think they can do hard quantum hard
classical things very quickly but
sampling but we end up with this like on
one hand
very device driven
primitives that might not correlate to
any data encoding or function that we're
interested in on another hand we end up
with very entangled things that
concentrate
and i think there's some goldilocks
principle in the middle we need
structured functions that take advantage
of things like entanglement but then are
also well correlated with the data and i
don't think we have good primitives for
that i think piecing together c knots
and poly rotations is convenient but
doesn't really seem to resemble any
natural data system that we see in the
world and what we need is like better
primitives to get us out of this
situation and maybe that looks like
restricting our space but maybe it looks
like using
larger blocks of functions if you look
at what people do in classical machine
learning people have put literally
entire sat solvers into networks and
trained them that's like quite a bit
different than a single poly rotation so
i i guess i'm tending to agree that
you know this phenomenon is kind of
universal for when you kind of choose
anything and everything in quantum space
and we need to be a little bit more
clever about the functions we use and i
feel like that is in some way the route
out but like maria if i had an answer to
which function classes are good for
these things i would tell you but i
don't
so
yeah i can chime in now so yeah i
totally agree with what jared and maria
just said
um and let me also say great talk nathan
that was really nice i feel like
kind of like a kindred spirit to you in
the sense that you're highlighting the
need for complexity analysis because
complexity can be pushed around
from one thing to the next
and um and that
you know you highlight it um
the fact that even sort of shot noise
comes into play like people don't talk
about shot noise a lot when they when it
comes to these things but really shot
noise is really
the key issue because baron plateaus
plus
shot noise equals untrainability because
uh whenever you want to decide which way
do you want to go you are saying
determine the size of the the sign of
the gradient you want to just make a
decision where do you go
um then shot noise can prevent you from
even making that decision and so so what
you find is that if you dial in more
shot noise then untrainability kicks in
at smaller problem sizes when you have a
bearing plateau
um but anyway yeah so um
and you also had this nice analogy with
the runner sort of running off the cliff
and and there's like we we had this term
called a narrow gorge for that sort of
phenomenon that you were talking about
um and i like i think it's really
interesting this pre-training strategy
that you had there's been a several
different pre-training strategies in
fact i think jared has one as well um i
think we do need some some serious
theoretical analysis of these different
pre-training strategies that people have
out there um to see how well they scale
so i think that's definitely definitely
an area that we can that people should
focus on
is understanding the scalability of
these pre-training strategies um and um
but yeah like i said you know
kindred spirit in the sense that
nathan was emphasizing the same idea
that that we emphasize in that when it
comes to barren plateaus you shouldn't
assume anything everything should be
proven and avoiding baron plateaus is
subtle and it's hard um there's been
several papers in previously in the
literature that said like maybe you can
avoid it with gradient free optimizers
or hessian based optimizers and then
this turned out not to be true um and
then you know people also said that um
because baron plateaus were first shown
for variational quantum algorithms by
jared and company uh people said well
maybe it doesn't apply to to quantum
neural networks maybe it doesn't apply
to qml and people will sit and then sure
enough it does right so
as
our group and nathan also showed
um that that actually qml architectures
do
suffer from barren plateaus
and it's interesting to also think about
that symbiosis between those two fields
the variational algorithm field which
focuses more on you know chemistry and
optimization and variational state
preparation
and how much of the results can we
import there from variational quantum
algorithms into quantum machine learning
um
and uh it looks like a lot um but
they're still we need to do that that
work and you could even have new
phenomena that are not necessarily
present because
now you have training data right and you
have the embedding and then you can have
new issues that arise with training that
aren't present in variational quantum
algorithms so
um yeah so it's definitely worth kind of
trying to study that symbiosis between
the two fields but also understanding
that there might be new stuff that show
up when you have training data
um
and uh and just to take a step back
uh you know when it comes to training a
qml model
baron plateaus aren't necessarily the
most important issue there was a
question in nathan's talk about
um other things like local minima
and uh you know so so and there's also
the issue of generalization error so
really what we would like is
architectures that avoid burn plateaus
avoid somehow avoid local minima and
also have good generalization error um
all three of those things and so in the
future you know ideally we'd like to
study
you know architectures that that satisfy
all this or try to come up with
architectures that have all those three
properties
um and one thing i'll just end on as
i'll say there there are some
you know we've recently studied quantum
convolutional neural networks
and it looks like this might be an
interesting useful architecture in the
nisk era because
it's been shown to not have bearing
plateaus
and also it's not impacted much by noise
because it's relatively shallow in depth
and so it doesn't have this noise
induced bear and plateau issue and also
tends to have good generalization so
that's one possible candidate but you
know it would be i think definitely we
need better
um on zotz's in for qml
because there's obviously in the field
of vqas we have some nice problem
inspired onsauces but i think we're
lacking
that as much in the
in qml um so yeah i'll end there that's
great that's great actually i was going
to i was going to ask the question you
know shouldn't one talk about rg in this
context but uh maybe we should come back
to that after after our own has a chance
to
to
yeah
so um yeah thanks for uh having me on
and nathan for the very
thought-provoking talk i think there's a
he gives us all a lot a lot to think
about
about uh you know next next direction to
go in
i i was thinking about like the
the challenge of getting a good a good
quantum speed up it's a little bit like
the hardware people have the problem of
you want a cubit that's both isolated
and addressable and for algorithms you
want something both that the quantum
computer can do but the classical
computer can't do and you know both the
needles are are pretty hard to thread
and
i think
you know one there's a few different
ways of coming at it and what i like
about your talk is it kind of does both
it says you know what are the basic
primitives that we have as well as like
how do you put those into a high-level
algorithm um
and
the uh
and the idea of using you know that
gradient of these entropy of these
divergences can be nice even if the
underlying divergences are nasty is a
cool point
on the on the subject of primitives so
if i were to
you know
uh
one thing that
yeah
the primitive part that that makes i
think is uh
i think is most interesting but also
most most vulnerable is
the
um estimating these properties of of
gibbs states
so um
you know i like this this swap amar test
but i'm i would worry that if it works
in a in a high temperature limit if it
relies on being a high temperature limit
you know the one where e to the h or e
to the minus h converges rapidly then
you know in that case we also have
classical algorithms in that high
temperature limits now
you know it could be that these scale a
little bit differently and and there's
there's some room for advantage there
but i think that's where
as we as we look more into these
techniques i think that'll be that'll be
an important place to look um
and
i guess
yeah the other so you know
i i agree with um with maria jared and
and patrick about
well they said a lot of different things
but but the idea of
you know what is what is the right the
right onset right and nathan's talk is
getting at this a lot um
it's kind of it's also you could say is
as
what are the right primitives to try
that we we might try to then build on
with some sort of some outer loop of
optimization um
and one of them might be that with a
with a quantum computer you can try to
uh sample from a thermal state for
example
um
and uh
and maybe there's something and it may
also be that there's something about the
high temperature expansion of a gibbs
state where quantum computers can do
better than classical you know it could
be that each of them are polynomial time
but but it's a better polynomial
equanimally and uh
yeah so i think those are
nailing down that primitive will be will
be something that will be of interest in
general not only for this
um
you know for the learning problems here
but
but maybe just to understand the quantum
simulation more broadly
um
great
so one thing you know i'd like to
comment about that you know is that the
gibbs state is i think just a it's just
a com
it's an especially compelling example
when it comes to the rainy divergence
just because of the fact that there's a
closed form expression for the inverse
of the density matrix in that case
but that being said you know like if
fundamentally all that we need is we
need some good method of approximating
the inverse of a density matrix of
interest
and you know well we took a look at some
uh you know lcu related approaches that
effectively boil down to polynomial
expansions for this
i think that the you know there's a host
of different methods that could be
coupled with these ideas both for proxy
for instead of using series uh
expansions for these things might
involve more subtle ways of either
representing the gibbs state for the
like the opposite temperature
hamiltonian or um
end up
involving um
just yeah some uh some completely uh
other way of approximating the inverse
but you know that again i i think that
here this is just kind of a baby step
approach you know the taylor series
expansion was the easiest thing to do
but figuring out with gibbs state
preparation where the real computational
bottlenecks actually show up because you
know like if you're using markov chain
methods it's the kind of the gap of the
markov chain that ends up creating the
computational bottleneck you know if
you're taking a look at using the
announce series based approaches or like
the pulen walchen
algorithm then it ends up becoming like
the high temperature versus low
temperature limit that's relevant
and you know so i i think yeah this is
this is a kind of an interesting
question right how do we figure out the
classes of operations that are in some
sense reasonable or cheap
to end up doing and i i don't quite know
the answer but we need to keep poking i
think
yeah i mean i think you could try to
make some generous assumptions right
like you could you could assume
that you're that your markup chain mixes
rapidly
and then that would that would help your
quantum computer but it would be of less
help to your classical computer yeah um
but if you assume that the high
temperature expansion converges then you
know that could be that could be help to
both of them right
um
but yeah like it's true that if you if
you use more knowledge of the
hamiltonian you could you there's a lot
of room for creativity there yeah
i also like that
you're able to use some structure in the
problem to get one of these
i mean the thing that's plagued us for
many years that we wish we could do is
compute the log of any of these
probabilities or just sample an output
directly the probability which i guess
goes under the name strong quantum
simulation which we can't often do
but i hadn't really considered the idea
that
there might be some cases where these
log
objective functions like if you make
enough assumptions they become usable
and in fact they become very useful and
so i think that's quite a nice
uh departure because if you
oh no yeah sorry go ahead finish
i'm too interrupted
oh i was i was just gonna like draw some
other analogy to if you look at what the
the closest analogs are classically to
the way we're actually training things
um on quantum models they're not often
like a deterministic feed forward
network they're maybe a little bit
closer to like what one does in
reinforcement learning or has some
probabilistic method and you go read
papers on what they do there and they
use things like the score function which
depends on these log so the
probabilities of the outputs which we
could use if we had those but we don't
um but this is kind of inspiring for
there might be cases where you can argue
that you do have access to this but in
the general case it's forbidden um so
and one thing i wanted to you know say
similar to what you were saying about
you know the rl type approaches
is that you know the um
that we when it came to this idea we
totally ripped off the boltzmann
training community because the only
reason given the stochastic gradients
that you have in those cases that you
don't suffer from immediate and fatal uh
gradient decay problems is uh because of
the fact that the derivative of the
objective function ends up being a nice
ratio of two expectation values
and uh so
basically what that um
that that's a that's entirely what ends
up saving the day so i guess the thing
that i think is also important to pay
attention to is we often will talk about
the classical limit
of quantum neural networks i i think
that we should consider a plurality of
classical limits yeah
in some cases we really should be
considering probabilistic models in
other cases we should be considering
deterministic models
and the the analogs between quantum and
classical may be stronger or weaker
depending on what classical analog we're
assuming
uh which i don't know if you want to
steer the conversation or shall i just
jump in
with a bit of a different thought
um yeah actually good no go ahead i was
going to say something but no please i
actually uh yes a different thought
would be great
yeah so uh one thing i wanted to just
raise so there's a lot of literature on
the idea of over parametrization
actually both of neural networks and and
also of uh you know quantum circuits and
training so it's a bit of sporadic
evidence that if i get the picture that
i haven't researched myself well
then we can say you know from quantum
control theory and so on and so forth if
we have a lot of parameters in our
system and so as many as for example the
dimension of the hipaa space all of a
sudden the optimization problem gets
kind of very nice and you know we get
nice properties we find like global
minima very easily and so on and so
forth
so now
now we could say okay if we just scale
these quantum models to lots of
parameters one day then things are fine
but here's obviously a different problem
and most people are aware of this in the
community although a lot of students are
not and this is that the way we get
gradients out of quantum circuits um
uses these parameter shift rules
and they have the problem that or not a
problem but they scale linearly
in so when you think of the number of
circuit evaluations they ski linearly in
the number of parameters of the model
so and your networks don't right neural
networks you get a gradient you run it
forward you run it backwards you've got
two runs you've got your entire gradient
vector or whatever in quantum
you know machine learning you have got a
lot of um you know a lot a lot of
computations you need to do so the
scaling all of a sudden that we see in
deep learning won't happen and you know
i'll also be interested on more of a
meta level if other people see this this
is the problem here or if you know there
are ways out or what about this tension
of that we can't go that route
i think that deep learning in quantum
is going to be incredibly difficult
for the uh
personally because if you take a look at
i mean the closest classical analogs i
really think with deep quantum neural
networks
are would be deep boltzmann machines
and well restricted boltzmann machines
turned out to be easy relatively easy to
train
uh the the there's no analog of back
propagation that's as powerful
for a deep boltzmann machine and so the
gradient you you lose basically all of
your gradients after you know four
layers or more
um
and
this ends ended up meaning that you need
a near infinite number of samples to
practically train them so i'm actually
not convinced about the wisdom of deep
learning when it comes to quantum
settings just because the great the the
rapid gradient decay that you get
through the chain rule
can't be dealt with in the same way that
you can do with a deterministic neural
network
just to quickly add so this this wisdom
also like so a lot of it is from quantum
control theory and i think i think jared
knows quite a bit about this again i
think but uh you know this idea that
actually
things train well things optimize very
very easily under certain settings if
they're just like large enough in terms
of parametrization so just to add those
now
yeah just to add to that it is
this problem
maria talks about this is a
it's a troubling one because i think
many people don't quite
realize it and we're tempted to go into
this
scheme where we imagine there's going to
be a billion parameter quantum network
that
takes advantage of all of these over
parameterizations to make everything
convex but if it costs you a billion
times more we already have trouble
sampling it at once and to my knowledge
the
the best you could do in these
situations is the gradient algorithm
that nathan and others have put forward
that uses a lot of extra qubits to do it
and square root the the number of
parameters and i was trying to figure
out if this is kind of fundamental like
our our quantum out like quantum
gradient runs incompatible with like the
dynamic programming method one uses in
back propagation to get the gradients in
this complexity and it i haven't been
able to prove it but it kind of feels
like it is because you can do stochastic
classical back prop but you have to
track the whole path and if you track
the path then you have to measure at
each point it becomes a path integral
it's kind of a mess
and i feel like this is a kind of a
problem and perhaps the only solution i
see around it once again you kind of
like restrict your class of circuits to
ones that are amenable to training but
what does that do to your classical
complexity it's hard to say
um
and so i feel like this is a problem
yeah
well that's a that's a really
interesting
point i think
about about deep deep nets
well actually i guess brian did you have
a question first or
i mean it was less a question than sort
of a comment on this conversation i
don't know if the non-panelists they're
allowed to say things don't go for it
yeah but uh
one thing i mean
sort of related to this question that
sort of linear in the number of
parameters and things one uh thing we've
played with
is instead of doing gradients um we have
this uh sort of alternative algorithm
where you do something more dmr-gs you
sweep over gates and for a given gate
you find the
objection objective functional for that
gate and then classically optimize that
gate exactly and so
you're still paying linear in the number
of parameters you're making much much
larger steps per um
per step and i think sort of as a meta
philosophy or something or an approach
um
instead of instead of trying to do
gradient descent where you're going to
have to do a lot of work and take a
little bit of a step and a lot of work
and a little bit of step if you can do
a medium amount of quantum work and then
a lot of classical work and take large
steps this might be sort of
one one route to make progress on this
this
problem of many many parameters
so
um
yeah so i agree with with brian that
they're sort of
you know when you say gradient descent
there's uh there are many many flavors
and some of them could be like line
search or things like that but i just
want to speak up briefly in favor of
deep quantum learning
um i always tell people that
you know variational quantum algorithms
are kind of without loss of generality
right so we've been thinking about baron
plateaus terrible
but that's for like random
initializations but you're always
allowed to take your favorite quantum
algorithm you know take shores algorithm
and then do gradient descent from there
right take the adiabatic algorithm do
gradient descent from there so whatever
you know so
you know maybe we don't
so you know on one level you could say i
have no idea what the algorithm is i'm
going to start from the identity from
doing nothing and then doing gradient
descent from there okay maybe that
doesn't work so hot i'm gonna start from
a random point do waiting defense from
there okay maybe that doesn't work so
hot but i could start with with some
heuristics like adiabatic
um
where we have some apriori ideas that it
should
do okay in some limit and uh you know
it's a reasonable heuristic to try but
we also know it's limited and and start
from there for adiabatic so i think
um
you know
it makes it in a sense very hard to make
general general pronouncements
and
you know because if you look at the
right way variational quantum algorithms
are just all quantum algorithms
so it's uh
you know if then if you want to talk
about the limitations you can say well
um
it's almost like the limitations of our
knowledge like i don't know how to
initialize it
or
um
you know actually doing a link by layer
doesn't work or something like that but
yeah i just wanted to close this out
yeah i wanted to throw this out here
because i also like only only recently i
got really you know like i knew about it
but i really sat down and read the
papers about quantum signal processing
and this whole idea you know there was
this really lovely paper about like a
grand unification of quantum algorithms
and this idea that actually quantum
algorithms you can often understand them
is actually a sequence of something that
you can think of as a variation circuits
but for which you know the parameters
right and in this set i just wanted to
add this into this idea that maybe all
quantum algorithms are
can be understood as variation circuits
and vice versa in some sense so that is
actually quite an interesting point and
i sometimes wonder if that could be so
some some idea like that for those of
you who know this idea this could be a
nice answer to start from and it would
be much more generic than holy rotations
for example
well
deep down
just just to push back a little bit on
on these viewpoints you know you could
also say but look
we know universal quantum circuits exist
and that's what all algorithms are about
so you know there's nothing more to say
about algorithms than you know we know
what the universal quantum algorithm is
or something but but it doesn't help us
very much to say that we know what we
know it's just a universal circuit right
so it's um
[Music]
you know yeah i guess this brings in the
more trendy topic today and machine
learning of uh inductive bias which is
people kind of internalize that
universal function approximation for a
network is not enough to explain
good performance because you're
in high dimensions almost everything is
extrapolation so your network by virtue
of things you might not even have
considered like the training strategy
particular connections the way in which
data is collected has a preference on
unseen data a bias
and that bias is sometimes very good and
when things match the problem structure
very well like
images tend to have a certain
convolutional structure to them and your
network matches that your inductive bias
tends to look very good and i think when
we write down certain quantum primitives
we're ending up with inductive biases
that are
somewhat random rather than somewhat
concentrated and i think this is kind of
along the lines of what umesh was saying
is that we could start from like a short
algorithm and then it would have a
certain
bias to it what would the training
landscape around that look like if we
put in parameters at different places
but
yeah it's um
there is a certain aspect to which the
primitives we choose will buy us in a
direction
and we need to be able to pick good
directions i think
so one thing i wanted to comment about
maria's point yeah i've i've always
wondered you know if to some extent it
might be valuable to start thinking
about these algorithms more from the
perspective of block encoding and
singular value transformations because
yeah you could and you can end up
getting an arbitrary polynomial
transformation any block you feel like
by variationally optimizing i guess it's
just for all the examples that i think
people like myself and others who've
spent time looking at this
we can end up getting kind of closed
form expressions for the polynomial
transformations we want to do in the
sub-block
but it
i've still kind of wondered yeah just
like you maybe maybe there is something
that could make this a powerful onsauce
i guess it's just you have to make sure
when you're using it that the blocks
kind of line up with the parts of the
space that you want to control and don't
end up
scrambling it
the i but the other thing i i would say
i kind of you know
that i think is a little bit of a
challenge about how to try to port over
the ideas of deep learning
over is that there's a couple of things
that are kind of implicit about existing
ideas of deep learning the first is
that's kind of implicit is this idea of
information locality that all the
information that you need to perform a
classification okay use lstm or
something like that that breaks this but
in most mod deep models you've got all
the information you need to make a
decision in the final layer but if
you've got a quantum neural network that
has entanglement between all of the
layers there's no notion of the
information actually being physically at
any individual layer in the network
and that's one of the challenges is you
know like the entanglement induced baron
plateau stuff that we looked at ended up
posing but another
big issue that i think ends up coming up
is that there's a compositional
structure that you end up getting for uh
for deep learning where it's like
f o g o h o blah blah blah all of your
results and so when you take the chain
rule you get all of those derivatives
kind of multiplying through and so that
ends up often leading to these
situations where the derivatives kind of
end up chaining at least classically
through to end up giving you some pretty
small values
and so my concern is that unless we've
got a lot of really good insight about
how to set up our
deep structure we might either run into
this problem of too much entanglement
between the layers or we might just lead
to the chain rule causing our gradients
to decay uh beyond the point where the
one over epsilon limit allows us to um
to resolve them
so it i don't i don't think it's
entirely a lost cause but i think it's
going to be you know
coming up with a practical way of
scalably doing deep learning at least in
an amplitude encoded uh quantum machine
learning task i think it's going to be
pretty freaking hard
great so
so switching
you know
gears just a little bit so
would you like to also comment about um
um
you know this type of quantum machine
learning and how it stands in relative
relative to uh
uh quant shadow tomography and
and you know
yeah so i mean okay one of the things
that you know like shadow to shadow
tomography has become increasingly
popular lately and for good reason i
mean it gives a great great way of
coming up with classical models that can
be used in order to predict unobserved
measurements
from quantum systems using a small
number in some cases of samples
but i guess one of the things that made
me kinda and my co-authors kind of
excited about looking at this is these
generative tasks fundamentally are
things we can't use shadow tomography
for right because the the end goal is to
produce a particular quantum state
knowing the expectation values of poly
operators doesn't necessarily
help us for this particular task
so that's that's one of the reasons why
you know i think that there's a big
difference but i guess kind of a broader
question that i that i i always have is
you know what are the ultimate limits of
techniques like shadow tomography right
can we
can this end up replacing most or
potentially even more controversially
all of uh the
the quantum neural networks that people
use at the moment
i don't i i don't i don't know i suspect
that i suspect that you know the in the
long run the shadow norms for the things
that we'd be be predicting might be too
large in order to make the computational
the sample complexity reasonable
for it
but
i really wouldn't be surprised if all
existing quantum neural networks could
be reasonably simulated with shadow
tomography
i mean i could kind of do different
things maybe we're saying different
things when we're saying shadow
tomography i'm often
jumping to like the classical shadows
representations of states which i know
is kind of a subset of the more general
like um
determining
observables and things like that and
what it is in my mind is a fantastic way
of creating
parsimonious representations of quantum
states that you can then try to infer
things from that if you do say the poly
version of it the more samples you take
you slowly converge higher and higher
moments which are often what you want to
predict for many systems and i think
it's great for doing that and to some
extent you can do
generative-ish type things where you
take sketches of states and then you
kind of interpolate in this density
matrix space which is what i think
robert and john did in one of their
recent papers for efficiently learning
ground states
and then i think there's these other new
results on top of it which
i'm still trying to wrap my head around
but you take like pairs of quantum
states and measure them and then somehow
you get all n-body poly operators at the
same time their magnitude very easily
though you have to be very careful and
clever about getting the signs out and i
think these kinds of sketches are very
very good
representations of states but you can
plug them into many different machine
learning algorithms i think most of
their traction so far has been in kernel
methods but i could imagine
they're a general tool that can be used
in other things as well
all right so maybe i shouldn't maybe i
shouldn't be so secure about the
immunity of these ideas from uh
classical shadows
point taken
so um
so actually we're coming back to maria
and
jared on on this question
so um
i think uh nathan expressed this view
that um
that um
quantum machine learning might be more
more interesting for
dealing with quantum states than than
for for dealing with uh
with uh classical objectives so
um would you comment on that and also
comment on uh
on the industry interest in quantum
machine learning and in view of you know
in in the context of that
um i could start with the uh with the
first question
so yes and i think so especially like
one of the first people who always
argued this was uh alejandro pedomot so
he's with zapata
so he often like talks about why do you
always talk about supervised learning
let's do quantum neural networks that
are generated but also nation has like
done a lot of work on that like in early
days the problem was generative models i
mean they're beautiful they're used in
in classical machine learning a lot
but
and in some sense like we can talk a lot
about them but actually if you think
about um learning theory you you will
find that even if you take supervised
learning which is a much simpler form
it's already very very hard to study i
mean the problem of supervised learning
is this like flavors of optimization of
generalization of like the statistical
samples you have to like conclude to
your large distribution you don't have
access to and whatever so like that
problem is absolutely horrendous to even
start opting classically it's horrendous
to start touching it with a quantum
perspective so now you take out the one
thing in this problem that gives you a
bit of an idea if you're doing well or
not which is the supervision and you get
it to some unsupervised learning and so
you can obviously start comparing
probability distributions and there are
ideas of losses there
but the reason why i'm always shying
away from it and maybe this is just a
lack of courage is really that it gets
even more messy and
and also like sometimes you know for
example if we talk only about
optimization we might get away with this
but i think we should actually change a
little bit our figures of merit and our
figures of marriage should include
generalization as well and that becomes
very hard to analyze
[Music]
but we can say things about it at least
for pac learning and models like that
there's been a lot of great successes
over the years with uh some more
theoretical approaches to ml
yeah so i may be forgetting exactly
exactly how you asked the first part of
the question but i think it was on
supervised versus unsupervised and
generative learning was that correct it
was more it you know it had more to do
with whether the learning involves
actually quantum states or is it you
know whether they are whether the
definition of the of the of the question
itself involves quantum states or
whether you have a completely classical
objective in mind
um i would say speaking for myself and
the people most adjacent to me the the
objective is kind of to do
um anything that is deeply useful to
someone um
and so
that can include receiving quantum data
in some shape or form it could include
if we could manage it uh to encode
classical data in the into a quantum
state that maybe is now on some manifold
that much better represents the problem
than classical
i think there's a lot of open questions
as to like it's very easy to say look at
these advantages we get for quantum
states and it's a little bit harder to
say um
you know where did these states come
from uh how do we get these multi-qubit
states in that we didn't know how to
build from a gate sequence or something
like this
and i think some of the recent results
suggest that there are things we could
do
of data that's transducted in from a
large quantum sensor that could be very
powerful but today a lot of quantum
sensing focuses on rather than like many
qubits of data they use many qubits to
enhance the sensitivity of say an
effectively one qubit or phase type
measurement which is a lot different
than trans
to copy of them and then trying to do
something with it and don't know what
the concrete realizations of that look
like but maybe to get to the second part
of your question that's certainly
something we're
interested in in history simply because
i'd say the quantum application space
especially in machine learning is quite
open and we're open to anything where we
smell hints of large advantage
you
so
i i guess one thing i mentioned question
is is that you know where does what are
the primitives that we're gonna use
so
if you think one primitive is that a
aquatic computer is good at
you know making good states because it
can simulate the quantum markup process
it converts to them
then
you know that's going to lead to some
learning problems about about many body
physics and then if we got better at
optimizing general objectives objective
functions like you know we were maybe
hoping for a while that the adiabatic
algorithm had some advantage in
tunneling through local minima or kind
of like
tonguing these we can work on uh
escaping saddle points with a cubic
advantage you know maybe there'll be
some some kind of edge that a quantum
algorithm can get for general optimizing
general functions
you know that then then it'll look
better for for classical problems but uh
you know it's sort of like
once you have the engine then then we
can like design the rest of the car and
the upholstery history and so on but we
it really depends what the underlying
engine is i think
that's it yeah
yeah
maybe just to build off what arm was
saying and
with relation to like adiabatic
optimization i think is a good analogy
because
we often when we say adiabatic
optimization some people have already
like automatically internalized
the kinetic energy part of that is sum
over sigma x
which
has a certain if you want to call it
inductive bias to it which is it's a
hypercube graph laplacian a bit string
space it likes to make neighbors out of
single bit flips and when you traverse a
path to build up a phase that carries
with it some bias as to which functions
it should be to be good at we normally
talk about this in terms of the gap and
i believe though i've never proven this
like the manifestation of this is in the
problems that are often pointed out in
the literature where
you see a
a slowdown when you use this particular
type of hamiltonian to solve a problem
and you get a path time that has to be
so long that it's harder than random
guessing and to me that's like a
prototypical example of very poor
mismatch of like a quantum primitive
that you've chosen for the particular
classical problem and i think you're
right that we need these better engines
and we they're probably not not going to
work for every problem but it would be
fine to find one problem or a few where
we have a very powerful engine and we
can
help solve it maybe not in the worst
case but in the average case
excellent um any any final thoughts
before
we are probably at the end of our
yeah i'll say something so uh maria
mentioned earlier this over
parameterization effect and
uh and i tried to sort of mention
earlier that you know we don't just want
to find
architectures that just solve the baron
plateau problem we also want to solve
the local minimum problem and
because you can get exponential scaling
from that as well and also have to solve
the generalization error problem as well
and so
um you know i think that's something
that we're interested in the future you
know or in other people maybe as well um
is really thinking about how do we get
sort of all of these in one basket
and um and i think that you know we've
we've been looking at there is always
always these trade-offs right you find
out that
on zotz's that are highly expressive
like hardware efficient onslaughts
they're hard to over parametrize um they
require a lot of parameters to get that
over parametrization effect
exponentially many and so uh on the
other hand if you have less expressive
onsauces they're easier to over
parameterize and so um and so anyway i
think it's it's interesting that we're
kind of running into these sort of
trade-offs and of course we want to make
sure that the trade-off isn't such that
you know the perfect uh situation is one
that you can classically simulate or
something like that but um but in any
case like it's interesting to try to
search for these sort of things that
have solved you know solve the bear and
plateau problem but also solve local
minimum problem and have good
generalization error
and um and i think that's sort of the
key of what we're
uh looking for um and what we need
and and i think qml definitely could uh
um benefit also maybe from the vqa
variation algorithm literature where
as aaron was saying you know you
actually do have these nice problem
inspired uh situations so yeah
you know one last thought i know like
we're running late but and maybe we
should add to the list of things that
the first answer we're now looking for
you know this one thing that will bring
us further is not the one that you know
generalizes well trains blah blah blah
but it's actually the one where we can
do mathematical analysis easy so maybe
we should actually step back and forget
about all these measures that we're
currently trying to optimize and just
say we need a model where we can have an
a to z understanding so the icing model
of quantum machine learning in some
sense maybe that is what we should do
actually with our time
that's that's a great thought to end on
so uh well thank you everybody thanks
nathan for a great talk and thanks
aaron
jared patrick for for
for all your comments fantastic
thank you bye
bye everyone
you